all right today we're going to find out
why ai
is much better at governing people why
poor people really should pay more taxes
and how donald trump is just a normal
human all right we'll dive into it we're
looking at the ai economist by
salesforce research now salesforce
research
has kind of created a simulated world
environment where they can place agents
in it and the agents
they can move around they can collect
resources
they can trade those resources and they
can use those resources to build
houses and that will earn them coins
and each agent wants to maximize its own
coins but
also there's the government and the
government can set
taxes so they collect money from
everyone and they
redistribute it and the goal now is to
going to be
that the ai handles both the agent
and the taxes and we want to
maximize the social welfare of the
entire population
all right that's the goal so the paper
here is called the ai economist
improving equality and productivity with
ai driven
tax policies by stefan cheng and
alexander trott
and other people from salesforce
research and harvard
university so
as i said this is a simulated
environment
and the simulated environment works like
this
there is a 2d plane kind of like a game
playing field and in this game there are
agents
here you can see the agents there are
always four agents
where oh down here
what are you what are you doing in the
corner come on
be productive um
the the the agents are
in this world and they can do certain
things they have certain actions at
their disposal so first of all they can
move around
they can move down left right and so on
whenever they walk past a resource tile
they collect the resource this is stone
and this is wood so there are two kinds
of resources
and then the last actions the agents
have is building
a house one wood and one stone
will create one house and the house
gives you coins
so this is a house and that will give
you coins
but how much coins you get is different
from agent to agent and this represents
the agent's different
skill levels this is an abstraction
and the kind of economic theory behind
it
is that the income inequality in people
one of the main drivers of it is that
they are skilled differently
and therefore are able to
they are able to convert one unit of
labor into
more money than another
lower skilled worker so this is
here represented by the fact that maybe
if this agent here
builds the house they'll get 50 coins
but if this agent here would build the
same house they'll only get
10 coins so we'll call this here a high
skilled worker
and this here a low skilled worker
now the last thing sorry i thought last
thing before but the very last thing the
agents can do is
they can trade so if one agent has too
many resources and the other
one has not enough they can trade those
resources
among each other for those coins so once
you build a house you collect some coins
you can then
either go and collect more resources or
you can use those
coins in order to buy resources off of
other people
this guy this is unlucky no coins
no houses and no resources look at them
oh yeah so you also can't move across
the water
here um you can only move on the grass
you can also not
move through a house which gives you
some interesting
abilities because you can just build a
house right here
and um yes so and you can't
move over other players but these are so
the rules are pretty simple
and the goal here is for the agents to
maximize the number of coins they get in
a thousand steps
so the number h here is one thousand
which is the number of steps
that the agents can take before the game
is over
and it restarts again so each agent is
using
reinforcement learning in order to learn
how to achieve the maximum number of
coins now the policies of course going
to be different depending on
whether that is a high or a low skilled
worker
the catch here is that outside of this
there is the government the government
here
let's draw this big house with the
flag of our fictitious nation which
is like this
that's the flag and the government will
observe what's happening here
and they will issue a tax um
taxes so it will issue a tax
distribution
now how do you imagine that so if you
imagine
the government says something like this
for the first ten coins you own
you owe us five percent of that
um for the next 10 coins so from 10 to
20 you
earn you owe us 10 and so on so if you
earn even more
you owe us more and more percent of
those extra coins
this is what you might know as a
progressive tax schedule the more you
earn
the more percentage-wise you pay on that
extra earned
money this is what you might be used to
but there are other tax schedules
and the exact histogram you see or the
exact
how many percent for which amount of
coins
that is the action of the government so
the government decides on the taxes
and the taxes are just collected from
the income so if you
if an agent earns these coins then it
has to
pay taxes to the government
and the government will redistribute all
the taxes it has collected
equally among the population so if you
pay a lot
you might lose through this process and
if you just pay a little taxes you might
gain through this process
so that's it that is the basic
premise of the game the agents are using
reinforcement learning and i believe the
newness of this paper is also that the
government now
is using reinforcement learning in order
to determine the optimal
tax policy there is kind of this inner
loop here
and there is this outer game where the
government also tries to maximize
the rl and what does the government try
to maximize
good question it is a measure that's
called
social welfare now social welfare
consists of two things
and they have this here way down in the
paper social welfare
in this paper consists of two things
first of all
economic productivity which basically
just means
how many coins have has anyone produced
it doesn't matter who but just the total
amount of coins produced
the second one is income equality and
this
is related to the the genie index so if
you plot the cumulative distribution of
wealth
a fully equal society would be a
straight line because
50 percent of the people would have 50
of the money and so on but
a almost all true societies
have something like this where fifty
percent of the people might have
ten percent of the money and the rest
fifty percent of the people has the
other ninety percent
and the measure of inequality is this
area here
um this is called the genie index and
one minus this area
is what this paper has as an equality
measure
so the higher this number the more equal
is
the society in terms of their income
distribution
now what is actually optimized for here
is this thing
equality times productivity so you want
both
to be high your income equality and your
productivity
there's a trade-off here of course but
you can you can have multiple ways to
trade that off and that will give you
the different uh thing they call this
the
social welfare function
and that's the thing that the government
rl agent
optimizes for so you can see here
already the free market even though it's
the most productive produces the most
coins because if you haven't free market
means no taxes
if you have no taxes then people are
basically encouraged
to uh earn more money because they don't
have to pay taxes on them right
as soon as you tax them they're less
encouraged to earn more money
and therefore if you have no taxes the
most coins will be earned
in total but the equality suffers
so the equality is the lowest among
these things considered
if you compare that to the ai economist
the ai economist
achieves the highest social welfare
it achieves the highest equality but it
doesn't suffer
as much in productivity as other systems
here and the baseline systems are first
of all
the u.s federal system this is not
particularly tight to the u.s this is
basically every system
uh or most of the systems that you have
currently in the world
is the progressive tax system and the
size formula which i believe
is an economically theory-based system
which is a regressive tax schedule
you can see them down here where the u.s
federal will be progressive means
the more you earn the more
percentage-wise you pay
while the says formula will be
regressive which
generally means the more you earn the
less you pay
i believe this was derived under some
assumptions to be the optimal tax
distribution
and the ai economist will come will come
to
will come to this in in a second
let's actually just look at one of these
things first one of these games
how this plays out the cool thing here
is that they have pretty flashy
animations
so you can look how does one of these
games turn out now this is a
free market game and you can see the
agents moving around
collecting things building houses and
you might notice that
one of the agents namely agent one is
just
building all of the houses and generally
just kind of being a dick being in
everyone's face
and kind of building things everywhere
and the other ones don't and
or or just very few like the light blue
on the
on the bottom left build some houses on
the right you can see how the
distribution of wealth
is is structured and you see agent one
ends up with
most of the wealth now the size of the
circle i think is the total
productivity so
you can see this grows over time mainly
because agent one becomes so
rich and if you analyze this if you
analyze what's happening here
then you'll see that agent one and
i might be
yeah they have a graph up here so so it
is very interesting what happens
this is kind of the same game so agent
one here is this orange dot
and agents two three and four are these
dots here and this graph here is
coin from trading so how much money they
win or lose from trading now you
the green bars are trading wood and the
the brown bars are trading stone
so you see agent number four which is
the lowest skilled
um the skill is just determined at the
beginning
of the episode it will just make all of
its coins basically by selling
wood and agent 3 will make all of its
coins by selling stone
and agent 2 will collect both and sell
both
and agent one will just spend money
in trading so you'll have a
specialization here agent one
which is the highest skill one right
here will
buy resources in order to build more
houses because
it clearly profits from building lots
and lots and lots and lots of houses
so it will use that money to buy more
resources rather than go in collecting
them
while all the other ones basically
forego building houses
in favor of they just collect the
resources and they just trade them way
to the agent one that's more profitable
for them than building houses themselves
so you see this kind of specialization
emerging
in these games which i find i find this
to be pretty cool
that you see something like this like a
really stark
division of labor emerging just from
these very very
uh small set of rules
and you can analyze this game in
different ways they have a few more
plots where this becomes
quite apparent that um
sorry that that these agents specialize
so you see here resources collected
sorry about that resources collected
uh if you have the lowest skill and the
highest skill
labors the reas the lowest skills
they mainly about this this should be a
pen
they mainly collect resources while
the highest skill labor mainly
goes for building things it doesn't
collect resources
but net income from building is really
high
while everyone else just doesn't build
at all
all right so we have a division of labor
emerging
now this was a free market let's
actually compare
the different algorithms so if you look
at social welfare this is this thing
here
equality times productivity you can see
that the ai economist will outperform
over time over the training progress it
will outperform
all of the other systems so it will
outperform the free market
the u.s federal tax system and the sas
formula
um if trained for long enough which is
to be expected right if you put rl
onto a cost function it will then
optimize that cost function but it's
pretty cool to see that it
had there's a lot of lot of headroom
here over what we currently have
now let's look at some of these
strategies
it comes up with so what do these games
look like
where the ai
has imposed different tax strategies so
this is with the size
strategy you see that here again you
you see this inequality emerging with
the yellow player here
building most of the houses with the ai
economist
again there is inequality but you can
see at the distribution that
agent one only ends up with about half
of the wealth
where if you compare this to the free
market here
then agent one ends up with
like two-thirds of the wealth right this
is the game we saw before
um but there is not qualitatively that
much of a difference
uh but there is in the end result
all right let's look at what the these
policies actually come up with
so what is the tax policy that the ai
comes up with so
this tax policy outperforms on this
social welfare metric and
this is very interesting right so
first of all you see that it's right
zigzag it's like
down up down up uh which is already
weird so the first very weird thing
is the the spike at the very bottom
so that thing here what's that thing
here
those are the poorest people in your
society and you're taxing them
the highest right so just imagine this
you're here uh downtrodden by life
abandoned by society you have no money
no house no nothing
and you're just trying to get a job
you're just
getting like a little bit of money and
you can buy a cheeseburger and then the
government comes
give us that us that money
come on so basically
this these are the poor and the poor
in this system is just fu fu the poor
now the reason why this happens is
pretty clear
right the reason why this happens is
because you want to encourage
people to go here to
earn more money right so so it's not
like the government makes any money from
the poor people independently of how it
how high it taxes them
but it is a basically an incentive
structure to make them move
over to the somewhat more productive
population
because here it's assumed kinda that
even the lowest skilled ones can move
over a bit
if you just tax them enough at the low
brackets right
so um this this is what i find to be
you just have to realize that it is
so hard i believe it is almost
impossible to encapsulate
what we really want in a system into a
formula to be into a cost function to be
optimized it is
so incredibly hard and you see that here
of course it is going to result in a
better social outcome but it just
doesn't
feel right to tax the poor at what
60 okay
so f the poor right and then you get to
to this to this level right here and
interestingly
if you earn even more you'll
be taxed high again right so this this
um
this we're kind of used to that you earn
little you
pay little you earn more you er you pay
more
but then comes this entire valley here
what's up with that
right like wtf doesn't matter
and this can be this this is now of
course the same reasoning as you have
with this
science formula here is where the
rich people you want to tax them
less so that they are more productive
such that they
generate more coins and even though you
tax them less percentage-wise
they will end up paying more uh money in
absolute terms because
because you basically encourage them to
produce more so
that is that is can that is the i guess
the reasoning behind this
but what you have to re you have to
recognize what's happening here
right what are we optimizing we're
optimizing this productivity
times equality right and what do we get
you see you get two big values of
attraction
one here and one here
and that means that this algorithm
favors a two-class society
right and i believe this is this is
partially the
limitations of this simulation here the
fact that you're only a f4 agent the
fact that you can
only do two things either collect or
build right it encourages a two-class
society
this specialization that you saw right
so
you say these here are the money makers
right
and these here are the collectors and it
is very hard
to move from one group to the other
because if you
you earn more coins as a collector
you're here and you're really
discouraged here
if you move there you want to move all
the way over here
right now the people that are are
already over here if they earn an extra
coin
that doesn't bother them too much so
they're very encouraged to earn more
money
but the very the poorer people on this
side
they're basically discouraged from
earning more money
because the system needs them to stay
at that collector level right
so the system encourages the two-class
society because
we have not built social mobility
into the into the
into the equation we have not
built a measure for social social
mobility into the cost function
and therefore the ai doesn't care that
the poor people will stay poor and the
rich people will stay rich
uh it just knows that this is the best
outcome for society overall
given the cost function that we had
again this just doesn't seem
like fair to us like what we want we
want someone
to be able to make it over here right
even if they start out
from the bottom and
so we'd have to we have to build that in
so we have a system
that is effing f the poor right
no social mobility mobility
no and then look at what happening at
the end
what's happening at the end this is
beautiful very rich people
these are the money maker right this is
the
this is the monopoly guy top hat monocle
wearing scrooge mcduck bathing
in coins this is where the the
government makes their money
and um the discrepancy
is really stunning because you could
also argue hey
why don't we apply the same reasoning as
we applied here and here right
it's not is it not like the case that if
the rich people
if if you tax them lower they'll pay
more money and so on
i believe again this might be just a
result
of this how the simulation is set up so
we'll move away quickly and we'll come
back to this here is what i find
particularly interesting
about this paper which just confuses the
heck out of me
it is a double periodic game so it's an
inner outer loop game
what do i mean by that they have these
episodes right here is the start
and here is the end
and they subdivide this into as we said
1 000 steps so an agent is here and they
can do step step
step step step and it can perform these
actions this is the agent
there are 1 000 steps here and the agent
just tries to collect as much coin so
this is your classic rl
problem but also they divide this
into 10 what they call periods and i'm
just going to draw
maybe four periods right so this thing
here
they call one period
where the whole thing is an episode
now the purpose of the period is that at
the beginning of each period
the government the government
can impose a new tax schedule so the
government
doesn't only fix the taxes once but it
can
change the taxes over the course of the
episode
right now
this is what i find i i just don't see
why so now you're formulating the
tax giving objective as a sequential
decision making
it's like the government saying well
today we have high taxes but tomorrow
we have low taxes and the day after that
we have high taxes again
and it just doesn't make sense to to
for any government to do this um
what you should do is you should set
taxes once
at the beginning of the episode and then
see how that turns out and then try to
maximize
uh your tax schedule because all we're
looking at
um we're only ever looking at how the
taxes are at the end right the things
that we've examined
are just the last taxes that the ai has
issued
we don't know the dynamic of what
happens in between this might be
super wild actually what the ai does in
between
and i just don't see the framing as a as
a
as a sequential decision problem and i
believe
this is just an over engineered thing
because
someone wanted a reason and here is the
architecture
right you see someone wanted a reason to
put
an lstm in there someone is thinking
like well rl that means like
sequential decisions and so on and rl
in this outer loop the way i propose it
would just be a one step
per episode decision which is a banded
problem and as we all know
bandits are boring so they didn't want
this to be a bandit problem
they wanted to be a sequential problem
and that's why they made this period
thing
which i find dumb um
so another factor here and i'm going to
tell you how this relates
to the to the weird rich people are
taxed high
another factor here is look at this it's
a cnn
an mlp an lstm and an mlp and the agent
as well
and i can tell you right now the cnn has
two layers
two and the lstm has like 128
units in its hidden state so these are
tiny tiny models
and it is not a model based rl it's
model free or else proximal policy
optimization
and the the um
the ability of these agents or planner
to learn anything substantial here
i believe is just not uh super
duper uh well right
so the i i believe that
these are rather dumb agents and you can
see the tax
rates given by the planner is fed
into the agent model but i don't
think that the agent given such a small
model
can actually adjust to these inputs
because
you have to do some pretty good logic in
order to
from these tax brackets to determine uh
how you should act right now
what i think is happening is the agent
just kind of is aware of its skill level
and through its rewards it's trying to
maximize
its in future rewards and then when the
government changes the tax rate
it will not i am almost
positive it will not directly change its
response to that
but it will kind of observe that
something's happening in the world and
then
adjust maybe a little bit its overall
strategy
uh but not in that particular instance
and it will be delayed or it will be
like an overall
strategy and this might be
one of the reasons why the tax brackets
here
might be screwed up because
who says who says if i were this ai
what i could do is in period one through
nine
i make the taxes really low for the rich
people
so i just encourage everyone to make
more money right
like come on become more productive and
i get the benefits of that
and then in the last episode and last
period right i just
freaking jack up that final tax bracket
it's like
you you have lots of money give it to me
right and then you just redistribute
what you got there
to the poor people in the very last
period and thereby you achieve your goal
of this social welfare function
but of course this is not sustainable
because all the rich people would just
be
kind of screwed through that and move
down again but it's the end of the
episode so what are they going to do
so i think the fact
how this is framed that there are just
two different ways to get
coins uh the fact that this is this
periodical
nature of the outer loop all
might lead to something that becomes
slowly more and more and more
uninterpretable uh
still cool though all right so the final
thing
they do this with humans yes real humans
so they let humans try it
and they have this interface here
and the humans they behave quite
differently from the ai so there are a
few
different things where the humans act
but look at that here
ai economist this is what the agents do
right so this ai economist is
the tax strategy so just take these
developed tax strategies
and let the humans be the agents so that
the
you you just want to observe how the
agents act and whether or not the tax
strategies also work when it's real
humans acting in this environment
and not rl agents so compare this
to how the humans act the humans they
just build their houses in like
neat little packets or straight lines or
stuff like this i just i just find it to
be
very funny now there are some things
lacking in the human environment which i
find really important
so first of all they have no cost for
moving which
i guess is minor but um
second of all they have no trade and i
think that is that just kills the whole
experiment
because now of course what you're gonna
get is the wealth is just going to be
proportional to how much
you get coins per house which is
different for each agent right
so to me that that is now a pointless
experiment if you can't
uh trade because the outcome is just
predictable
and i don't think that the human
behavior
changes in response to the different tax
brackets i think they'll just
do and however they can make money
they'll make money they'll build more
houses until it becomes unprofitable and
that's it
so i don't see the i don't see the value
of these experiments even though they
show that again the
ai economist outperforms the other
tax strategies in this equality times
productivity metric and also in another
metric that they
measure um the second problem i have is
for the human experiments they take this
distribution here
they say well the a this is one of the
distributions that the ai came up with
but you notice the lack of the
fu poor people and the lack of this
big spike here for the rich people which
i find
um are one of the two features of the
other distribution so i think there's
quite a bit of variance in what this ai
comes up with or maybe it's just because
this is periodical but this is
really confusing because they show and
discuss
that other distribution and now all of a
sudden they say
well we use this distribution that was
also created by our ai and it seems to
be qualitatively quite different
in any case um let's look at how
the humans behave under the um
under the different strategies so in the
size formula you'll see that
yeah the light blue person here is kind
of spreading out a bit
probably playing correctly everyone else
is just neatly building their houses
look at
humans are so territorial and most of
them they kind of
they kind of stay in their little corner
and they're like this is my
corridor i'm gonna build my houses here
in a nice
thing and
under the ai economist again you don't
really see a different thing
just because the taxes are different uh
the qualitative behavior is quite the
same
it's just building straight lines and
here
i think the difference is more between
the humans so i think it's not always
the same humans
and um the difference might be more
between the humans and you kind of see
that the humans clearly don't
haven't really trained or discovered the
optimal strategy they're just doing
something and you what you're seeing is
just a result of the taxation
uh it's not different behavior and this
here this this
is the best okay watch the on the bottom
right the human
they're just first they do something and
they're just walling off
walling up the other players and
this is this is the best i'm going to
build
a big beautiful wall and i'm going to
have the orange guy
pay for it it's donald trump
in the game amazing and look at the end
they actually managed to lock in the
other players so they can't move anymore
donald trump wins amazing
though actually the yellow player
appears to win economy-wise but
what do you want with lots of money if
you can't move
so i again i find these human
experiments to
be rather pointless here because you
disable trade
and you don't train the humans to find a
good strategy
all right but in that i find the entire
paper to be pretty cool
code is going to be released they
promise
and they have checked that they have no
ethical
problems of course i invite you to check
out the paper if you like content like
this
please uh subscribe share and leave a
comment of what you think
thank you so much for listening and bye
bye